first focus evacuation very one fire in
this room you will need to evacuate we
also do use the cross a staircase
designed to use the stairs with the
please without the others to exit the
room before the fire escape door when
they can be given assistance 70 points
is in the public can't decide listen
sweet please do not delay the evacuated
graduation to collect immediate audience
please do not return to the building
can I please remind you to switch off
your mobile phones portable
and we competed I am representing Prince
Walker and he was pretty full house and
the connotation of takes on those
committees at the last war council
meeting
yeah well put country right politics
presence again when I have these as a
George Boleyn who is being substituted
by a council sparing non members
attending very social
okay minutes of the meeting held on the
10th of June I will copy those
declarations of interest if it should
come up please make sure that you do
there are these discussion with offices
and because most of the documentation
90% of it is actually in pink paper
potential what we've decided to do is to
take the meeting into private and
confidential so on that basis I will
read the resolution members are publicly
the poetry in the producers probably can
be present the remaining report contains
exact information and I worked there for
us he now leads me meet Lee this live I
resolve with another section 108 section
4 of the Local Government Act 1972 the
public excluded from the meeting for the
following item of business on the
grounds that involves the light of
disclosure and exempted information
defined in paragraph 3 pub under the
schedule 12a of the anchors